hey guys welcome back to a brand new vid
we're back on foreign organs they're
gonna be talking about the new news that
just came out with the season 7 route
we've got tons of stuff to talk about
warden and Valkyrie reworks
no more marching fire content and tons
of other things so as always like the V
if you do enjoy subscribe if you're new
I covered the informational side of
foreigner that beam balance changes
patch notes hero updates leaks new
updates all type of stuff and with that
let's get started with today's video
it's a real quick they'll be timestamps
in the description if you want to
skipped your preferred for real quick
there's gonna be timestamps in the
description if you want to skip to your
preferred part of the video
I understand it's gonna be a pretty long
video season 7 also starts today August
2nd the day this video is going live and
as soon as this video goes live I should
be live-streaming trying to get
gladiator to rep 60 so come on by I'll
be checking out some of the new season 7
stuff as well and a foreigner is going
to be Gamescom showing us gameplay of
the new PvE marching fire mode on August
23rd and they'll also show it on the
weekly dev stream so I'll be sure to
recap that for you all of you as always
but for the marching fire constant today
it's going to be gear progression
because it's changing in marching fire
in the current build of the game every
hero has access to all 18 different
stats and it's higher depending on your
armor but there's limitations because
we're finding gear isn't too great and
it barely gives any stats and it's too
difficult to find any more variety in
terms of builds so the new version of
marching fire now gear will have perks
instead of gear stats all perk effects
are passive so no catapult perks perks
will have less power than feats and the
perk players will have will be shown on
the scoreboard during the match as you
can see all gear has different perks on
the left and if you put armor that has
similar perks like devourer you will get
more points towards that perk and in the
middle it has colors of all the gear
ranks in the game so the better gear you
have the better perks that you can use
for later build the higher you go so you
want to make sure that you have gear
with a similar perk so you want to have
some people that are going to need to
change their builds and get new gear and
then if you want to level up gear you
can increase the amount of points the
perk has as you can see on screen with
the dashed lines buy the perk the more
points you have on a single armor the
less pieces you need to stack in order
to get the perk which adds for more
diversity of perks so you can get more
perks and maybe have three or four on at
one time in terms of how many perks
we're going to beginning we're gonna be
getting seven offense seven defense and
seven support perks that can be used in
along for some different builds and play
styles depending on what you like each
hero has a predetermined perk which is a
combo of some of the versions that I
just mentioned offense defense and
support and each hero also has one
default
that they start with which are gonna be
seeing on screen so you could pause to
see what your main default perk is and
the higher that your rep and rank the
more options you will get it does not
increase damage it only increases how
many perks that you can equip at one
time now don't worry about your current
gear if you have some currently of
course if you got it before marching
fire all that gear will have perks on it
so you don't need to grind for new perks
you may just need to grind for the
specific type and the correct gear set
that you want and stuff like that but
all gear regardless if you got it after
a before marching fire will have perks
on it regardless and remember this is
only releasing after marching fires out
this is going to be in October so we
have a little bit of time before this
releases but please let me know your
thoughts about this in the comments
below next up we're gonna be talking
about the reworks first up is warden and
the goal of this rework is the basically
give him more options the shoulder bash
can be feint to bow at any time during
the animation the charge shoulder rash
is also much longer than before these
shoulder bash cancel and a guard break
is now removed sadly but he still has
more options but you can of course
cancel shoulder bash and do a GB but
it's not considered a soft fate and it's
not as smooth so it most likely will be
counter guard broken the - forward heavy
attack which is on screen will catch
people who unlock roll out of the
shoulder bash if you happen to faint it
into that move the top-heavy finisher is
now unblockable and does 40 damage on a
hit and the zone and sprint detect can
be chained into the heavy unblockable as
well and lastly the side lights are
going to be faster but for them before
from 600 down to 500 milliseconds making
them like I said a little bit more
faster so overall pretty decent Reaver
key as it seems like the devs are saying
that he has a lot more options
personally I don't use warden so any
award of maine's in the comments let me
know if this is a decent rework next up
is going to be the Valkyrie rubric and
she'll crush now guarantees a single
light attack and it has a shorter
recovery than before you can only do it
during the heavy attack and not after it
so it's going to be considered a soft
feint but if you try to do it after the
heavy attack lands it would be
considered a GB instead she basically
has every three hit combo chain in the
game just basically think of anything
that you can think of so like heavy
heavy heavy heavy light heavy light
light heavy really any combination you
giving up in your head she basically has
that type of chain combo now sweep is
down the guard break button instead of
backwards heavy and it's a lot faster
than before full block stance is now the
way it should be and not used to counter
every move in the game and which makes
it a little bit more balanced the second
light and hurt
attacks on I'll 400 instead of 500
milliseconds making it a little faster
just to know berserkers lights are 400
milliseconds so definitely keep that in
mind most of her light attacks that
being the finishers or starters on now
faster like I said which are now gonna
be 500 milliseconds instead of 600 so
like I said just a little bit more
faster and the shoulder pin is more
viable doing more bleed and somebody's
and physical damage as well like I said
before I'm not a warden or vow to remain
anything like that so any of you guys
that play those two characters let me
know if these seemed pretty good if
these are good changes if these are
nurse I loved in your thoughts in the
comments down below
continuing around there's also going to
be a new map called secluded keep and
that's going to be played in elimination
skirmish tribute duel and brawl so
basically every single mode except
Dominion it's a pretty fast-paced map
and pretty small in comparison to the
other maps in the game basically this is
a whole map of a fortress surrounded by
water personally I think this is a
really cool map except I really don't
like how it's in Dominion though which
really sucks new weapons is also being
added into season seven which are
available right now I got all the photos
of them from the stream the first ball
you're seeing are armored Musha
berserker sent and conquer second is
gladiator Highlander Kensei and Lal
bringer third no bushi Orochi
peacekeeper and Raider the fourth group
is shaman shinobi Shu go key in Valkyrie
in the last two are warden and warlord
let me know if you guys think about the
weapons in the comments both love to
know your thoughts and as well we're
going to be getting some rep 60
progression a new outfit is going to be
coming out for rep 60 called the
conjured Chronicle any specific effect
called sulfuric spark which is only
available a rep 60 which is pretty nice
it's better than it's just a regular
battle outfit so I'll take it and the
new content for the week this week is
going to be a new effect called tempest
call which like I said is a new effect
looks pretty cool I'll show the video in
the background and then afterwards they
also showed this little teaser for a
possible upcoming summer event which is
pretty nice it's got the volcano when
the backgrounds are shadows all the
nights they didn't say anything but it's
definitely going to be in this summer
and we're definitely going to be able to
play before the summer ends which is
really cool so I cannot wait to post
this or talk about any of this new event
stuff and I'm really could be curious to
see what is in this new event and that
guy is going to be the end of the video
hope you guys did enjoy let me know what
your favorite part about season 7 is all
that good stuff like I said I'm gonna be
streaming as soon as this is over in
this video is live so if i come check
out the stream chill out and hang out
all that good stuff but yeah like to
view if you do enjoy discover if you're
new I cover the informational side a
foreigner that being balance changes
hero updates patch notes here leaks all
that good stuff
and my two most recent videos will be on
the screen debate you guys want to check
that out with that guy so paper girl
yesterday thank you for watching the
video and peace out
[Music]